[music]
poomen It's been a long time since I
've started playing games in the winter
[music] It
's just a little bit more to breathe in the morning air It's only
a matter of time before the promotion exam Ms.
Kiri  If it's
Erina-sama,
hey, how
are you?
It
's not that you should leave the academy right away, but the result is clear
.
There's
nothing to say in English There's nothing to say in English
I've been indebted to you for this amount of money The days have
passed so quickly I've tasted your dishes over and over
I don't know how many times I scolded you,
but you were always a team.
I wonder if that's okay, but even if I say that, how will I clear the exam
?
I don't know what you want to do, it's
delicious I
wonder if you have the will to survive absolutely
?
Become a truly proud dish from
jian
[music]
[applause]